what's going on guys this is Rob and man
I owe you guys an apology I'm so sorry
yes I I love to vape I'm a huge vapor I
didn't upload a Monday
Marvo request Monday video and there's a
reason for that there's a there's a
really good reason for that I went to
Wrestlemania this weekend and I totally
forgot about it I mean like a buddy of
mine flew in Thursday night a Thursday
morning rather I picked him up and then
we got together Friday and drove down it
was like a 12 hour drive down there and
and I totally forget just slipped my
mind entirely I was so excited for the
weekend so so I'm sorry guys I do
apologize for that it's like three
o'clock in the morning I just got home
I'm going to catch some Z's and I'm
gonna jump up and I'm gonna try to get
this video uploaded and sent out as soon
as I possibly can on Tuesday but yeah
I'm I'm really sorry about that you guys
have spoken by far the most commonly
requested thing the messages and
comments has been the Nova course so
I'll go ahead and do a video on that but
um yeah I'm I'm really sorry guys I
really feel like I kind of screwed up on
that one so so don't worry I'll get the
video uploaded for you all the other
thing is that WrestleMania was amazing
it was so fun
god people were crazy I mean in New
Orleans it was it was awesome Bourbon
Street was cool it smelled like piss I
don't I don't know what the deal was but
um but it was cool you know it was
awesome they had great food there we
actually went to this place called
Dickie Brennan's which was like the
super upscale restaurant we went there
the night before or the night of the
Hall of Fame induction ceremony which
was really really cool seeing jake the
snake' roberts and Razor Ramon kind of
picked themselves up with the help of
DDP and get themselves back on top that
was that was a really really cool thing
to see yeah it was it was awesome the
other thing is weren't like a thousand
subscribers now we cow like I took my
video my
YouTube channel yesterday and that's
when I realized that I didn't upload
that video I didn't have it because I
had intended to make it and then have it
as like a scheduled upload so it upload
today because I knew I wouldn't be back
here in time and I saw that it wasn't on
there and I was like oh my god I forgot
to make that video but but yeah we're at
like a thousand subscribers now I mean
that's crazy that's crazy and we have
thousands subscribers Wow
I mean a lot of you guys are posted all
kinds of stuff a lot of you guys opposed
a lot of criticism you know positive and
negative that's fun you know I mean I
take it all in and and and base like you
know expand my channel and grow my
channel from there and add new things
and so on and so forth so on so yeah I'm
really really psyched about that it's
it's it's actually really cool to see my
channel growing so fast you guys have
been fantastic with the whole YouTube
thing so I mean as I've said a million
times I said a hundred million times I
am here to bring you guys what you want
to see at the right time hopefully I can
actually get the videos uploaded when
I'm supposed to but I'm here to bring
you guys what you want to see and bring
the best version of that product that I
possibly can so um so yeah you know
thank you guys thank you guys so much
you know thank you guys so much for all
that you guys have been fantastic you
guys have been great know your your
support and everything so um so yeah
here's look into a thousand more I guess
so yeah be looking for that video on
Tuesday I'm gonna definitely get it
uploaded like I said it'll be the Nova
Corps so you guys will be able to check
that out I think you guys will be pretty
interested in the Nova Corps they're
like an intergalactic marine force but
their origins and how they turn out is
pretty interesting it's it's it's really
kind of cool so with that being said I'm
gonna catch you guys later peace now one
of the big reveals I think a lot of
people were really kind of curious about
this one of the big reveals and Captain
America the Winter Soldier was Stephen
strange and this I think was lost on a
huge number of people and because when I
was in the theater and I was watching
the movie there's a scene where they're
talking with one of the guys from Hydra
and they're part
about the weapon system that hydra is
implementing using the technology the
shield has this thing is how they
managed to circumvent and and to
infiltrate you